[Music]
there's this uh 18-year-old his name is
Hamza mashur
Hamza Hamza he just cleared security at
Denver International Airport and FBI
show up oh the agents have come to
arrest this 18-year-old who is diagnosed
with a developmental disability AKA
autism okay and they charge him with
Terror related crimes oh [__] how did he
even get in the
job huh let's go continue sorry oh yeah
he wasn't a terrorist yet he had gone to
the airport in December to fly to Dubai
and then from there either fly to Syria
or Afghanistan got radicalized all right
because he's allegedly plotting to join
the Islamic State Isis du the trip has
been spurred by over a year of online
exchanges starting when mashor was 16
years old with four people he believed
were members of Isis so he thought he
was talking talking Isis but who was he
really talking to like catfish Isis FBI
agents they catfished them they
catfished him but the thing is they
couldn't do anything with him because he
was 16 and a minor at the time so
instead they strung him along in
conversations for years 2 years until he
decided at age 18 to go join and then
isn't that entament 100% dude's
autistic oh that's not only are they
kind of pedy take it take him away but
that's predatory dude this fo's underage
did he break any law he [__]
Brainwashed the underage autistic kid
according to the Justice Department's
criminal complaint the four were
actually undercover FBI agents and as a
result of his conversations with them he
could face a lengthy sentence for
attempting to provide material support
to a terrorist organization but they
primed him they Juiced him yeah what a
waste of funds that's what they did this
whole time they created a terrorist and
then locked them up and red meat the
whole time that's crazy that's what they
do [__] dumb dude this happened by
the way in 2001 this is not new well
yeah then CIA created um yes what's his
name again Osama Baden well they were
funding him yeah they're funding him and
training Al-Qaeda you guys ever like oh
back then I remember telling a girl that
I really liked cuz like it was like time
to do a book report and she's like I
don't have my book report subject oh you
talking about how you know alqaeda is
being funded by by America
and then she comes back to me 9 days
later she like you know my dad said
that's not true oh and I'm like your
dad's a an idiot like that is absolutely
a fact why do people think that was like
some type of conspiracy when it was
clearly it's a complete fact yeah well
back in the day it's so hard to believe
a theory well right but it's written on
paper it's documented by the they did it
but they they just can't the money went
there it's like written by the military
it's there know and then they go he said
[__] right but her dad watching
enough Fox News she's like she n my dad
says nah I'm like Dad you know I was
watching the Golden Globes and then a
bunch of awards and nominations went to
his TV show called succession so I
finally was like yeah I should watch the
show and I watched the show and one of
the things that happened was one of the
older brothers was talking about cuz we
were at a club for a Bas party and he
was like hey here's the technique if you
see a girl that you like and she's kind
of hot but you're questioning how old
she is just be like where were you
during 9/11 she even got an answer
answer she's not old enough
oh a great answer the [__] does that
mean but nowadays they're old enough you
weren't old enough it I think you missed
it no that's a good that's a good way
though honestly that's pretty smart why
is it good because you don't have to ask
her how old she
is correct all right let's go ahead and
move on so basically law enforcement
agents first became aware of mcor's
online activities in support of Isis in
November 2021 but like I said instead of
alerting his family mro lores told uh
this uh article that FBI agents posing
as Isis members befriended him a year
later and strung him along until he
became a legal adult quote it's
appalling that the government never once
reached out to his parents even while
they were sending undercover agents to
befriend him online starting when he was
16 years old you could have got him to
do anything anything it doesn't that's
so stupid man waste this you could have
got him to play Zoo Tycoon 2o
instead Duty something our agencies are
notorious for developing like kingpins
like radicalizing people like Freeway
Rick Ross um that's an act actual drug
dealer in LA right the CIA um so there
was a uh the the Iran Contra um which is
basically the CIA was caught gun running
to rebels in the uh Contra Rebels but
they were funding it cuz they didn't
want the money them but they they were
funding it through selling crack to the
black communities so they had guys like
Freeway Rick Ross um sell the crack they
were they found guys that were like
smalltime drug dealers and then they
turned them into Big Time [__]
kingpins and then that guy would have
never been a Kingpin if it wasn't for
the CIA right he would have just been
selling like dime bags they set them up
yeah yeah but even this is like that's
so much deeper than this this is a
[__] autistic kid he's not going to
do anything did they knew he was
autistic I think like it's like a
pattern here right is like they create
their own criminals and then they make
them into yeah they make them these like
big [__] guys Gretchen Whitmer
kidnapping plot uh-huh same [__] it's
like oh so remember Michigan Governor gr
wmer no I don't remember she's the
current governor of Michigan I don't
follow Michigan Governor okay very
quickly so she she there was a
kidnapping plot against her right during
Co where they they got a bunch of guys
who are basically tardos who don't know
you know social situations anything
they're not rich at all they the FBI
entrapped them plan dinner parties and
like like oh yeah we're going to have
like a bunch of food here just come hang
out we'll talk about like kidnapping the
governor and like you know usurping the
state and like that went on for a while
for like over two years and then they
just busted all these guys and there
were more FBI agents than guys in the
group oh my God exactly undercover
exactly entament City USA but that's
what always happens so it's just like
and that all you know was just revealed
Court docum what do you think is a
motive for that for like a it's this
[__] it's like we are finding criminals
it's our it's a it's a speed trap they
need to build a case like think about it
right like you look like a better agent
if you're taking down a king pit you
don't look like a good Agent if you're
grabbing a kid off of the street that's
selling a dime bag but like if you're a
cop and like you got to meet a quota or
whatever you sit under the freeway
overpass you back up into the bushes and
you wait with a speed gun and you're not
supposed to be able to do that but they
do but also the biggest assets meaning
the guys that are the informants end up
with [__] immunity so a lot of the
guys in the mob world who were big time
tattletails and they were murderers they
got away with everything because this uh
FBI was backing them and now imagine
you're you're the cop backed up in the
bushes you got the speed gun and you're
online telling people go fast who cares
who give a [__] nobody gives a [__]
you're the racer next to them calling
them out right and see they're [__]
yeah and then you catch them all the
time it's like all of that in Number One
Cop number one cop that's catching
everybody the reason why they have a law
caught in trapment by the way so then
that's why so stupid dude you guys know
about the story of WHYY buer [__]
crazy the Irish gangster he's murdered
[__] tons of people right but like now
everyone's all up on these podcast cuz
now you know mob guys they're all
talking on podcasts right they always on
every podcast rat all of them are saying
but they all say WHYY Boulder was an
informat for the FBI he was Untouchable
he could kill whoever the [__] he wants
he'll just like and he was a murderer
cuz he just had his feelings hurt and
just blast somebody in a bar and nothing
happens to him or whatever and I'm like
that's crazy and Johnny Dev did a good
job too that movie was good what's it
what's it called I forgot the name serpo
is better though I think it's called The
Irish man no yeah know serpo is better
Ser old movie Irish man's Robert Dao oh
that's the old long one huh the long
which one is the Johnny Depp one jeal uh
is it Bol Whitey yeah yeah yeah yeah no
it's not that it's not called that it's
um Donnie dark no Donnie Brasco no it's
called white boy I think no it's not
called white boy it's called Black Mass
black
MK that's the one I can see why you
thought white boy
[Laughter]
pleas I don't give misinformation
here I just give mistakes but it's never
misinformation so what is what is the
entrapment law that's in effect because
like wouldn't that apply in situations
like this they have to they have to
investigate themselves and find
themselves guilty of it they because
they're FBI so only the FBI can
investigate themselves you dig it for
internal affairs what they're going to
do I know we I watched all the movies I
doesn't do [__] if you
Affairs tight so SI yeah if you develop
a small time criminal and make him big
time like Saddam Hussein like who's the
bad guy the guy who developed them or
the guy that decided to follow orders
right the the bad guy who decided to
follow order that's
[Laughter]
false